wollte eigentlich mal wieder eine
commands folge zeigt wenn man mit einer
bewertung oder drücke die daumen hoch
wer dennoch eine commands voll gewollt
weil die erste kammer richtig gut an
dann würde ich eventuell dann einfach
mal morgen kommen zweige hochladen wenn
ihr das denn volt münchen meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge der minecraft fähigkeit sich
warum ich zu behindert rede erwarten ich
habe mir wieder ein perfekt rausgesucht
aus dem text formuliert ich muss
wirklich sagen das weckt vormonat jetzt
schon wieder 19.000 effekt die mir da
eingesendet wurden es dauert zwar extrem
lang effekt rauszusuchen die ich noch
nicht vorgestellt habe uns weiter und so
fort
aber ich habe mir wieder 50 effects
rausgesucht und ich würde mich freuen
wenn du bis zum ende dran bleibt weil
das war eine menge arbeit und ich starte
das video selber und es wird nicht
einfach freuen wenn das dementsprechend
würde ich und wir fangen an mit picknick
nur eins wurde mir zugesendet von
computer freak 02 wenn du von einem
brennenden zombie angegriffen wirst
fängst du selber einzubringen an zu
brennen nicht anzubringen hoffe dass das
noch in keiner facts folge drankam du
ich hab jetzt alles auf nachgestellt hat
mich selber ideen und null gesetzt wer
nämlich jetzt angreift okay der sk lauf
gehört zu können jedenfalls jetzt
absehen wenn er mich an gab und er nicht
brennt dann brenne ich auch nicht aber
wenn ich ihnen jetzt einfach mal zurück
und er mich jetzt angreift dann
überträgt er dieses feuer auf mich also
nicht direkt schlagen aber ihr seht
schon das nenne ich hier wenn ich mal
hier in der 50 und wenn er mich jetzt
noch mal angreifen dann brenne ich
wieder allerdings wenn ich jetzt aufhöre
zu bleiben und er greift nicht jetzt
wann dann brenne ich nicht mich gar kein
computer freak 0 2 für den ersten fekter
folge und wir machen direkt weiter mit
der nächste weg wurde mir zugesendet von
michelle und zwar schreibt sie wenn man
mein karts auf schienen platziert in den
block darunter ab dort dreht sich die
lore schienen beim platzieren sind im
norden süden und die lore wären der
block darunter abgebaut wird sind osten
westen also ich brauche jetzt einfach
mal so wenn man hier jetzt auch mal f3
drückt ihr da ist norden da ist süden
und wenn ich jetzt hier ein mainka drauf
setzte hier mal theoretisch unter i oder
ii oder hier ich hatte einfach mal so
ein paar darauf setzt und ich baue jetzt
den block darunter ab dann seht ihr
schon mein tat dreht sich in diese
richtung sieht mein card schaut nach
norden
wenn ich jetzt zerstöre drehte sich
direkt in die schon alle in die andere
richtung ich weiß nicht woran das liegt
sie hat den effekt als tanzende mein
karts betete das würde ich jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen so erstmal den
raum stellen aber sie drehen sich auf
jeden fall
und dann kann dich michelle und ich
würde sagen dann war das auch schon
wieder verzweigen recht simpel aber
effektiv
wie so häufig für den dritten weg fliege
ich mal eben hier rüber zu anderen insel
alter das ist extrem cool ich finde hier
echt immer ich habe hier solches
widerlich mainz pont hier komme hier
sind überall so kleine inseln und hier
ist einfach so ein krater drin und damit
sogar noch so eine höhle rein also weiß
nicht ist extrem cool übrigens sich
neben grad immer noch nicht mit meinem
neuen pc auf weil der steht hier unter
meinem schreibtisch und ja ich bin noch
dabei die ganzen programme drauf zu
packen weil ich benötige er nicht nur
minecraft überhaupt zählen sondern auch
alle möglichen programme drum rum und
diesen teilweise mehrere gigabyte groß
und naja ist auch egal jedenfalls
perfekt zugesendet von christie 1 3 0 4
0 0 1 1 sg hallodri per zaun ist genauso
hoch wie ein zaun mit einer stufe drauf
also ich stelle das jetzt erst mal so
hin damit ihr das hier sehen könnt jetzt
stelle ich hier mal so zahlen hinter
einem zaun und jetzt mache ich so oder
sind einander fehler keine ahnung wer
kommt jedenfalls wenn ich auf einen zaun
auf gewissen ja ich gehe hier drauf und
bin dann hier eine halbe stufe höher
allerdings wenn ich hier drauf gehe bin
ich genauso hoch und wenn ich mal hier
jetzt drüber gehe seht ihr da ist kein
unterschied sie ganz einfach daran das
hatten wir schon öfters mal der zaun
macht 1 200 halb blöcke hoch aber man
läuft quasi nicht auf dem zaun sondern
man ist genauso hoch wie hier mit der
stufe wenn ich allerdings hier wieder
einen drauf setzen würde wäre ich noch
einen bock höher und wurde hier wieder
ein runter gehen also ich hoffe einfach
dass ihr versteht was ich meine
finde das ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
blöd mit diesen zahlen und ich würde mir
extremst wünschen dass man das
verbessern würde das die zaun textur
genau so hoch wäre wie das ja so dass
der zorn noch ein bisschen höher wären
so sieht der zorn hat auch genau so hoch
aus
der junge dieser kripo sieht der zaun
halt auch genau so hoch aus wie dieser
blog aber man geht jedoch auf und das
ist genauso hoch wie mit einer stufe
drauf weil die stufe einhalten blockes
und im zaun hat auch andere teil würden
einfach wünschen dass der zorn des yen
hoch gehen würde und ja das war effekt
nummer 3 oder 4 3 war das jetzt selber
sagt nur drei ich glaube das perfekte
nummer 4 stand in dem minecraft wickie
und zwar habe ich hier einen
wundervollen befehl für euch wenn ich
jetzt einfach mal enter drücke seht ihr
wird ein skelett erschaffen was einen
helm auf hat und jetzt denkt euch
erstmal was soll das ja dieser helm
schützt ich weiß nicht ob mich das ganz
auf times at night gemacht hat aber
dieser helm schützt die skelette vom
verbrennen
seht schon freunde es wird gerade tag
und das skelett es nicht am verbrennen
wenn ich normale skelett mal hierhin
setzen würde er schaffe es gestern wie
schon das fing an zu brennen aber das
schon okay es lockert in einer höhle
jetzt ist sogar gradl im freien mehr
oder weniger weil über ihn kann blockes
aber es fängt auf jeden fall nicht an zu
brennen weil dieser helm
dieses licht level quasi reduziert was
das skelett erfährt und dementsprechend
geschützt die wilhelm das gerät vom
verbrennen und genau das gleiche auch
mit irgendwie zombies oder so den helm
auf haben also einen helm geschützt die
da vor der sonne quasi nicht ganz
interessant und das heißt quasi dass ihr
euch nicht mit einem skelett oder mit
ihnen im zombie mit dem helm anlegen
sollte wenn es tages bzw ihr solltet
euch schon mit dem anliegen aber er
müsse auf jeden fall einen kleinen kopf
dabei einander schneller nicht
verbrennen kann und jetzt kann man hier
übrigens dieser befehl den ich hier
gerade euch gezeigt hatte das ist
einfach nur zusammen skelett das hier
ist einfach xyz koordinaten an das
equipment mit der id das ist quasi der
hellene auf hat und so weiter und so
fort
ich verstehe zurzeit ein bisschen mehr
von von befehlen seitdem ist diese
command serie gibt wollt ihr eigentlich
mal wieder eine commands folge zeigt
wenn man mit einer bewertung oder drückt
einfach mal daumen hoch werden noch eine
commands voll gewollt weil die erste
kabel richtig gut an
dann würde ich eventuell dann einfach
mal morgen 0,02 hochladen wenn ihr das
denn volt nummero 5 wurde mir zugesendet
von brian und zwar wenn ihr mal hier
schaut ich hab's ja schon mal gezeigt
auf einem ganz normalen zaun kann
schnell natürlich nicht rausspringen
wenn du allerdings einen teppich dahin
legt dann kannst du auf den soundtrack
ist es egal wenn ich von hier springe
oder wenn ich von hier springen möchte
dann kann ich auf den zaun drauf
springen mit dem teppich weil das
irgendwie kaputt macht aber wenn ich so
drauf springen geht nicht wenn ich
allerdings ein
eichenholz ein eichenholz unternehmen da
einen teppich drauf platziere seht ihr
schon so kann ich auch drauf springen
und so kann ich nicht drauf springt von
der seite das ist jetzt erst mal ein
bisschen komisch wenn man bedenkt dass
man hier wenn man hier sondern wie man
hier sonnensonde zaun hat dann geht es
von dieser seite einerseits und auch von
der anderen seite dass es vollkommen
egal ich kann auch mal ein zweites paar
anstelle mittel das sie entweder
seitlich kann ich hoch springen oder von
hier kann ich hochspielen hier kann ich
allerdings nur von hier hoch springen
von der anderen seite nicht und jetzt
kommt nämlich das interessante wenn ich
dieses tor aufmachen kann ich von hier
immer noch drauf ging aber von hier
ich weiß nicht warum das so ist weil
guck mal das ist offen
ich springe drauf und ich bin drauf aber
wenn ich das sound zu mache kann ich
nicht drauf springen keine ahnung warum
das war jedenfalls weg nummer 5 der zu
gesendet wurde von us kette von vorhin
finde ich extrem witzig extrem
interessant und ich verstehe es ehrlich
gesagt nicht ich weiß nicht warum aber
solche fakes muss ich wirklich sagen
finde ich extrem cool wenn ihr da solche
effekte in die richtung oder so dann
würde ich mich extrem darüber freuen
wenn ihr mir die auch perfekt nicht per
mail aber in das formular seine passion
in der beschreibung sehr einfachen link
in der beschreibung über dem link zu
meinem mikrofon glaube ich oder
irgendwie da ist der in den ersten ihr
werdet wahrscheinlich sehen da steht auf
becks formular vor und damit würde ich
sagen meine lieben freunde war's das
auch schon wieder für diese folge der
effekt wenn es euch gefallen hat und
nicht und ich euch unterhalten konnte
und ihr morgen eine kuppe folge haben
wollt dann will ich mich um eine
bewertung freuen und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal wieder guck mal das
ist ein t shirt